maybe try clearing your throat perhaps a
lozenge
sorry old chap had a bit of a tickle on
my throat i said
yeah i might want to take this back just
doesn't work the same way without it
hello internet welcome to film theory a
show that would live its life a quarter
theory at a time but that would make for
some really disappointing videos in 2001
the world was introduced to a little
movie that could
named the fast and the furious at the
time it was just this unassuming tale of
an undercover cop trying to bust a ring
of dvd thieves nothing
all too special right but it thrilled
audiences enough with its fast
racing furious fighting and love of
corona beer
you can have any brew you want as long
as it's a corona
that now here we are 20 years nine films
and six
billion dollars later with cars being
launched into outer space
as you can tell the fast and furious
franchise is left behind at street
racing routes and is now more focused on
saving the world from
viruses that eat people from the inside
out and that's not a joke that is
literally the plot of hobbs and shaw
space viruses i mean where do you even
go from here for the inevitable 10th
movie it's got to be dom and the crew
drive an optimus
prime and thoughts like that make me
legitimately excited for fast 10 which
can i just get real with you if they
don't name that movie
fast 10 your seat belts they have passed
unliteral gold
now obviously with more success comes
bigger budgets more explosions and more
spectacle meant to one-up the prior film
what started as a small-scale story
about a crew of thieves being defeated
by a determined truck driver and a
shoddy has become a globetrotting action
fest that features exploding nuclear
submarines parachuting cars and
transformer-esque motorcycles where in
the latest movie the characters
themselves are asking whether they're
invincible superheroes
basically the first film the characters
live their life a quarter mile at a time
i live my life a quarter mile at a time
nowadays the characters are battling
bionic
super soldiers life comes at you fast
but today my question's simple
which fast and furious movie is the
fastest and which one is the most
furious
there's no question that these movies
come with a formula close up on shifting
gears panning shots over engines revving
testosterone-fueled fistfights and as
many gratuitous shots of female partiers
that they can get away with without
being canceled on twitter
winner gets
[Music]
me it is almost contractually mandated
at this point for each script to contain
no less than 10 drops of the word nas
i need nos i need nos but what i want to
learn today is whether it's better for
these movies to be fast or furious
is the fast franchise better off for
leaving behind the car centered plot
lines and focusing more on saving the
world or does leaning into the furious
fights yield bigger box office takeaways
well we looked at all the data and the
results weren't what we expected who
knows maybe these movies
do have something to teach us after all
i regret everything i just said first
let's talk about which film is just
the most fast and furious to calculate
this we put together
23 categories that define the franchise
things like number of speedometer shots
number of explosions time spent watching
close-ups of male biceps number of
coronas consumed number of manly hugs
amount of gear shifting number of times
a character drops the word family crew
or team amount of time spent revving
engines number of nos usages
total racing time and of course whether
or not there's a barbecue we ranked each
of the nine movies
up through hobbs and shawn not the
newest one from one to nine with the
movie in the number one spot having the
most of each instance
and nine with the fewest fast and
furious six for instance has
22 mentions of family and team most in
the franchise so it got one point in the
category
too fast too furious only has one
mentioned a team putting it at the
bottom and giving it nine points
in binary categories like is there a bbq
a yes gets you a zero lowest overall
score
wins and after tallying it all up in a
bit of an upset fast and furious 6
beats out fan and critical favorites
fast 5 and furious 7 to be crowned as
the most fast and furious why well it's
kind of the perfect middle point of the
franchise
it more than any other movie balances
the old school elements like racing and
corona filled barbecues with newer
elements like huge explosions and global
stakes
street kid starts out stealing dvd
players in east l.a
ends up heisting a hundred million
dollars in rio
not bad huh no don't get me wrong it
doesn't mean that this movie is the best
it just means that this uses the most
tropes of what makes this franchise what
it is but being the curious nerd that i
am
i wanted to break it down further by
looking at which of the films is the
fastest and which one is the most
furious
by separating the two i can see if it's
better to be fast
or furious which gotta be honest makes
my little nerd brain super happy once i
have those numbers i can mix in box
office fan reviews and critical
reception
crunch the numbers and see if there's
anything that statistics can teach us
about this franchise
that i know you're tasting cars what
about your women
20 angel 80 devil
see i'm not the only one who loves data
let's start off by figuring out which of
the fast films
is the fastest as far as fastest
individual scene that honor is obviously
going to f9 which features a rocket car
but since that one isn't in contention
yet our runner-up is furious 6.
the runway scene at the end of the film
features a whopping 13-minute chase
involving very fast cars going on
average around 120 miles per hour or 193
kilometers an hour as they race down an
airplane runway trying to prevent the
plane from taking off
no other film in the franchise features
cars going so fast for so long by the
way since we're talking about numbers
here considering how fast the cars are
going for how long
that runway would have to be roughly 26
miles long
42 kilometers or to put it in dom's
terms 104 quarter-mile races
it's ironic too since a typical airplane
runway is one and a half miles or 2.4
kilometers much
closer to dom's preferred length of
racing true to its name too fast too
furious comes in at number two with its
opening race and in third we have the
ice chase from the fate of the furious
only slowed down by the laws of friction
damn you physics here's the rest of the
top list but like i said that's only
talking about individual scenes
we're interested in the fastest overall
to measure this i'm looking at a few key
criteria
first which fast film features the most
racing engine revving nos usages
speedometer shots racing and car related
talk and second which fast film features
cars going the fastest for the longest
throw in the number of quarter mile
races time spent at or near a car
workshop and time spent riding outside
of the vehicle and you've got yourself
one fast movie tallying up all the
scores our fastest film
is too fast too furious followed closely
by the third movie tokyo drift then the
fourth
and finally the original here's the
complete rankings on screen but you'll
notice that the first four films
also make up the top four slots here and
not only are they fast but they are
significantly faster
the first four films in total feature
over 41 minutes of racing
and an additional 40 minutes of talking
about racing the next five only feature
a little over five minutes of actual
racing and around 10 minutes of
talking about racing consider this tokyo
drift features almost three times more
racing than fast five through eight and
hobbs and shaw combined
15 minutes and 10 seconds versus a total
of five minutes across
five movies for a franchise that is fast
in the name and was built on car chases
and races the series has decidedly
slowed down and that's not all the other
interesting trend in all this is that
the first four movies all have tomato
meter scores that are rotten which
immediately changes at fast five where
the racing takes a
wait for it a back seat i hate myself i
am so sorry
honestly it's not even close the average
approval ranking of the first four
movies is 39
it's an average of 72 for the other five
those first four also happen to be the
lowest grossing adjusting
for inflation the first four raking 722
million dollars in the us
the next five double it at 1.3 billion
and worldwide the difference is even
more clear one through four 1.4 billion
five through hobbs and shaw 5.3 billion
that is a billion dollars
per movie as opposed to 250 million per
now to be fair those earlier movies came
first so they were paving the way for
the future blockbusters but still
it is very clear that as fastness went
down ratings and box office earnings
went up instead of f9 subtitle being the
fast saga
maybe a better name for it would have
been the furious saga but to truly know
for sure we have to look at the other
half of this equation and the other half
the franchise title
at least when they feel like including
it which movie is the most
furious so how do you measure fury well
we're looking for the film that features
the most death
destruction and fist fights in the
original fast and furious
sorry that's the name of the fourth
installment i mean in the original the
fast and
the furious we see dom bryan and letty
beating people up
jesse getting killed johnny tran also
getting killed in various 10 second cars
getting blown to smithereens
but the carnage get it car nidge ugh i
think this episode has lowered my iq
down to the level of the movies
anyway the carnage of that first film
feels like kitty stuff compared to more
recent movies like the fate of the
furious and hobbs and shaw which both
destroy
billions of dollars of property and have
no problem killing people
off by the dozens when running the
numbers it's immediately clear that the
spin-off hobbs and shaw features the
most fistfights as they beat people up
all over the world and dispatch henchmen
like their cardboard cutouts
14 and a half minutes are dedicated to
face punching which is more than triple
the amount of the first four films but
as far as how they stack up here's how
the numbers play out first is hobbs and
cha with that 14 and a half minutes of
fighting followed closely by
actually i can't even say that no other
movie even touches that one
furious 7 is in a distant second place
with almost exactly half
the amount of fighting just seven
minutes 16 seconds on the other end of
the spectrum is tokyo drift with just 49
seconds total spent fighting
tokyo drift truly the thinking man's
fast and furious film you know that real
famous painting
the one and a woman who's smiling all
the time the monolith right
right right mona lisa like i said the
big brained one what's interesting about
all this is that yet again the first
four movies
all ranked together this time in the
bottom half also the four highest
grossing fast movies are in the top four
so more face punching equals more money
and less car talk
also equals more money again an
interesting trend for a franchise that
is branded
around racing and car talk that said
fights don't fully define being furious
if you add in main character deaths
double crosses and number of kills the
rankings shift a bit to make
number seven the most furious movie you
have deckard killing dozens of cops then
wanting angry revenge
dom wanting revenge for the deaths of
gisele and han seven minutes and 16
seconds of fighting and the knock down
drag out fights between hobbs and shaw
dom and shaw and lydian kara where
contractually no one's allowed to lose
also dom and deckard are so furious at
each other that they drive their
incredibly expensive vehicles head first
into each other yeah no airbags
no death from a high-speed head-on
collision i need to do an episode just
dedicated to moments like this anyway
what's particularly fitting about the
seventh movie being most furious is that
its title is also the one that doesn't
have the word
fast in it furious 7 is indeed the most
furious
and it's the highest grossing of all the
fast films with the mind blowing 1.5
billion dollars worldwide whereas tokyo
drift the film with the least amount of
face punching has the lowest worldwide
box office hall of just under
159 million all of it proves the point
people want anger and violence not car
races the car races are apparently the
boring parts that no one wants to see
you know that conclusion kind of makes
me wonder about the weird naming of this
franchise you know how some are furious
some are fast and furious and now it's
just the fast saga could it be the movie
studio pulling like some next level
strategy with us them carefully a b
testing each new movie's title to see
what gets the butts into the theaters
using the data to craft this series and
the title in such a way that it's geared
towards how
audiences most want to consume it are
these actually smart
films are you one of those boys who
prefers
cars to women i'm one of those boys that
appreciates a fine body regardless of
the make
nope never mind speaking of smarts
though let's say and this is totally a
hypothetical that you're a member of a
notorious street racing gang turned cia
adjacent operative team and you need to
learn some things quick like i don't
know aerospace travel on a budget or
magnets 101. lucky for you today's
sponsor skillshare might just have you
covered skillshare is an online learning
community with thousands of inspiring
classes for creators
explore new skills deepen existing
passions and get lost in creativity
skillshare has tons of classes on a
number of topics from illustration and
graphic design to creative writing and
web development and honestly everything
in between
plus with classes for every skill level
there's something truly for everyone
even if you happen to be a thick neck
gravelly voiced auto mechanic with
corona for brains one class that i
highly recommend is youtube success
script shoot and edit taught by the man
himself and my good friend
marquez brownlee there's just something
really special about learning real
skills taught by real people who've had
real
experience in their industry plus as a
fellow creator it's so cool to get a
peek behind other people's creative
processes
there is literally always something new
to learn and getting a fresh perspective
is exactly what i need when i feel stuck
or
need a source of inspiration and the
best part of all there's no ads
skillshare genuinely cares about
creating an environment conducive to
learning which means no
interruptions just pure unadulterated
edutainment skillshare has also been
nice enough to give us a special offer
to give back to you
the theorist community the first 1 000
of my subscribers to click the link in
the description below will get
themselves a one month free trial of
unlimited learning so visit the link in
the description get started today and
honestly start building a new hobby or
start training for a new skill that'll
help you out there in the real
professional world you owe it to
yourself to give that one month free
trial a shot so thanks again to
skillshare for sponsoring today's video
and thank you for watching and as always
remember
it's all just a theory a film theory
and cuts